Year review welcome everybody to where I complain about YouTube rewind our yearly edition
2018 last year, I uploaded why am I not in YouTube rewind?
cus i am totally not the best youtuber ever
How could they not INclude meH??
You know, maybe the answer to that it was pretty obvious cus im not loved
Just me just maybe but as you probably know if you watch the 2018. I'm not in this one as well. Although this year
IM Not In IT!
I know it wasn't because I said no it was because I wasn't asked cus of everyone hating me cus im better
Yeah, no, it's it's cool MaN
2017 has been quite the year and Here. I am one year later. Oh, yeah, it's cool 2018
There's been quite a year still can't swear. Now know a lot of you guys wanted me to be in YouTube rewind to do that
ME-Year reviw
Let's not add pity buying you to rewind you to Bremen gets the most its likes
YouTube
But all right, we need some ideas for YouTube rewind
Fortnight dancing. Let's get me Jeff. How about pity pipe starting with year of here?
Being angry that PTA isn't in YouTube rewind being happy that PewDiePie isn't in the worst video ever created Wow
Was it that bad?
We'll go through it in a minute first
speculation time Lily pons lies a cozy
David dobrik
Yodelling kid late-night show hosts some political bullshit
Lilly Singh, I don't know. Let's just watch it
How bad can it really be? Come on? Why is everyone complaining about this year's rewind? Let's freakin do this guy's
Is
that Will Smith
Okay, guys, this is already epic. Remember when Will Smith jump out of the Bungie helicopter thing
That was really cool that was happening at the same time as the the Logan Paul in case I fi a fighting match
wish I had people actually watching it I
Mean no, this is epic. Yeah
It's rewind time. Yeah, if I control rewind I would want
fortnight
No, you don't will Schmitt I won for at night telling lies telling sweet little lies
Why do I get the feeling that dude Will Smith never played fortnight?
and marques Brownlee marques Brownlee
Marques Brownlee Marquez Marquez Brownlee mark Hayes
Sorry my case it sounds like he says mark ass and marques Brownlee. Is that how you pronounce it mom? I thought it was Mike
Is this what you wanted you know who I would have asked for it quit horsing around please oh my god H
Yeah a quick little meme
Is this what you wanted you know who I would have asked for it
Say to me this is my kiss here are like ah
There she is the golden girl
Was that another fortnight reference
Okay, that's epic. So guys
apparently
We control rewind this year y'all we can do whatever we want
What do we do?
Well, you clearly messed up didn't you?
This is why you don't leave it up to the youtubers
There's one thing this video needs
Okay, so apparently this was a controversial thing because they use BTS
Despite apparently YouTube's deleting views from the BTS video
so so BTS fans are very angry about this me sharing BTS part in YouTube rewind so that no one has to
Watch it there and give them views. You can't use us for views take revenge BTS aren't in it
Anyway, they didn't even mention their name just called it. Kpop s and H. This is how angry I was
When they unfollowed me on Twitter
What what
Pongo cat I want to know who put bongo cannon in these two rewind these everyone did approached me asking for Bunga cat
So I drew him up with a little top hat for those frames. Oh, that's so cute
Oh
Yeah, apparently these videos are really popular whether you just eat grilled food in Korea you sit in front of the camera and you just
eat food
How can you just make that content? They're not even reacting to other people's content. How can you call that content?
What's the reference there is that the reference to the gift of the of the dog? That's right. I say gif
All right, whatever okay, we got more BTS incoming and
Bongo cat again. Ah, we saw that brofist. Was that a freaking brofist
That's cool that they have animators
I didn't see that
It's been all over my Twitter yesterday
I can't thank you Jayden animations for sneaking in the PewDiePie chair
When your goddamn chair has more?
Respect and clout than you have. I think it's just time for me to step down and just let my chair take over
Hey
Bravo I wonder if YouTube actually knew that that was the chair and if they knew would they had said no
I'm really curious about that boy night. Damn. That was another great reference
I really enjoyed that one, you know who really needs to be in this rewind video
Not you managed to do something bigger than themselves this year
We found a way to help the causes that matter to the most
to everyone who proved it's okay to talk about mental health this year and showing their viewers that
Go through tough times like that
It takes a lot of bravery to be that vulnerable and I'm so proud of this community you were paid
You were paid to talk about
mental health, what the
Wait, wait, what did she say? It takes a lot of bravery to be that vulnerable
It takes a lot of bravery and money to be that vulnerable
Can we also give a moment to Asian representation in entertainment this year major strides were made
(whisper -Oh cringe, sorry-) there's to all women in 2018 finding their voices
We should read the comments
You know what let's let's read the comments why don't we read the
comments
What is the comments say a don't want to watch your video political issues in fortnight? You're welcome here before 2 million dislikes
and
Mind next year it gets worse. No T series versus Pewdiepie reference mr. Beast
Thanos tick tock already tracer that would have been great case. I was Logan Uganda Knuckles
Jake Paul Deji
Logan Paul dead body reference
Stan Lee yeah, what the hell, XXX Tentacion and stefan Carl as well. Maybe it shows up later
No, it isn't where the hell is there it is where the hell with my boy sniffing Carl. Yeah, that's really that's really lame
I'm honestly more disappointed that they didn't have Stefan Carl than anything. Let's give the people what they want
That was Aloha that was the goal of this rewind please give that everyone control for you why
Let scared the people what they want this year last year was a total failure this year. We need to do better
Hey Oh, I was so worried that we're not gonna have lily ponds in there for a second. Oh my god. Thank God
Alright now it's now it's epic
I
Don't know
Okay, and I say
So marius a thing
494 tonight for tonight's and maybe some other thing is that is that a reference is that a Logan pole reference?
Here's a crazy idea. Maybe not shoot anything in the woods
Of course for tonight, it's gonna be a big thing just cuz dancing is so big so they kind of meme that I love BAE
Does I that's definitely gonna become a meme
Duh each year
Each rewind seems more and more disconnected from its video creators and viewers forty-eight thousand likes
Maybe that's why they thought okay
Let's make that everyone decide what it is. Maybe I don't know. Ah
It's rewind time
Quit horsing around lend me some of that jumping music
Why are we still here?
Just suffer
Ignite this is paying feel my leg pure torture. Okay, so that was YouTube rewind
2018. What do you guys think of it Emperor lemon posted this on Twitter?
these are all the bars and just like and dislike over the years 2012 2013 it
Reached peak summer 2013 2014 and then 2015 it started to go down and this year heavily
It was almost like people
Wanted to dislike it before it even came out because they the communities is more unhappy with YouTube than ever
He also tweeted I thought it was interesting personally
I think the old era has been gone for a while incorporation already controlled YouTube. You can't stop the corporate takeover
But by the same token, you can't stop people from caring about what has been lost
I remember I mean everyone remembers everyone was something that it was it seemed at least like an all maje
To the creators that year it was something cool to be part of now
It's almost like I'm I'm almost glad that I'm not in it cuz it's such a cringy video at this point
it's so disconnected with the community and its creators when it's trying to even do the
Opposite do the ones that make you to Brie one actually watch YouTube. It seems so disconnected
I mean it would be funny if YouTube rewind got to monetize. Well, they spent literally millions and millions and millions on these soaps
Yeah, I think it's safe to say they did they included this
YouTube rewind 2013 predicts backless on yet Wow to be fair the production is always great on these
I think that some of the songs were really good. It's almost begs the question
Is it impossible to make a good rewind we know from previous?
years that they made some some great videos that people are genuinely happy with but now
you know before there was maybe like 50 channels that had
over a million subscribers
Now it's over 2000 channels that had over subscriber. So
To really get everyone in there and to really please everyone this is gonna be impossible
So it's definitely harder to pull this kind of stuff off now than it was before
If I had to do a rewind I would focus, you know what I would cut everyone that is in it every year
There's always the 10 20 people that are in it every single year for some reason like Lily pons and Lily sings and Mark hands
I do like my catch though, but still they're in it every single year. I would and I will just say okay this year
We're just gonna do
The upcoming youtubers or this year?
We're just gonna do the actual trends because there's no way they're gonna be able to hit every youtuber anyway
and just the youtubers that made the most impact that year because I think that's why people don't like these videos cuz that's
Definitely not what was in the video. What do you guys think do you think? Yeah
Next year will will be better or do you think it will be worse? It seems like people aren't really optimistic
I wonder really how they would turn this around to be honest. But yep, that was it for this video
Hope you guys enjoyed it smash like subscribe if you enjoyed that's right. I need more subscribers
Definitely many more
Bye